I'm thrilled to have here in person one
of my favorite guys that I've gotten a
chance to meet as the host of the NFL
Network since its inception this man's
football life is unparalleled unrivaled
to two-time NFL had a coach of the year
and also a recent retiree Bruce Arians
here on the program good to see you it's
always great to be seen brother to be
seen rather than viewed is that the way
that the phrase let's get right into it
what do you think of that national champ
ship game oh my gosh I thought it was
great
there it there's there shouldn't have
been a loser right on that that's one of
those games you just feel bad for the
for the team that came out on the short
end because there was no loser and just
great coaching on both sides well what
did you think of Saban's decision to put
that kid in it at halftime obviously I
worked out but what do you think went
into that Bruce I mean I you're sitting
there at halftime and you can't make
first downs you got to make something
happen and they knew they had the kid
ready to go and to me it was a great
decision was there a lot of risk to it
but you know I mean no risk and no
biscuit so you got to go with him at
that point in time and got to go well
I'd seem to me also that play call to
win the game that seemed like something
that that you to appreciate come out
shove it down the field like that with
that kid because you probably know what
you're gonna get
what do you mean a safe coverage you
know you just got the big sack now let's
play safe and don't give up anything big
and you play cover to and and he for a
freshman to look that safety off and
that's a vet safety is amazing and then
make that throw just throw that dart
right and also just the fact though that
the kid who caught it was a freshman -
do you think they were abundant and in
Harris the freshman running back was put
out there in the fourth quarter you do
you think that was born out of the fact
that maybe tool knew these kids better
than the than the first stringers in a
way well I think some some of us just
opportunity who's up next
obviously there's a ton of talent at
University of Alabama and it really was
a flashback game for me why so big
of coach Bryant that's what coach Bryant
we played three quarterbacks in every
game then you never knew why he was
putting him in he substituted sixty six
players in a game he did personally
because no assistant coach ever sent
anybody across that line all right that
was the fastest way to lose your job is
a substitute somebody and he just had
that gut feel and I think Nick had that
same thing last night with those young
kids well let's get into that Bruce
Arians he ran a coaching conversation on
the Rich Eisen show brought to you by
man versus food how did you get hooked
up with Bear Bryant cuz you're your
Virginia Tech guy right my my last head
coach at 3m was Jimmy sharp and he was
coach Bryant's offensive coordinator for
ten years and Jimmy is basically the man
had got me into coaching I pretty much
owe everything to him
I started at Virginia Tech he went to
Mississippi State called me put the kid
in a car you know get a u-haul and bring
your stuff down to Mississippi State and
that led to an opening at Alabama a few
years later we had beaten Alabama at
mississippi state that year for the
first time in 45 years okay so that
helped maybe that helped and Embree
blurred who was a genius mmm-hmm
reinvented the wishbone I was at state
with him when he invented the wing bone
and it was a version of it
we had a great receiver named Marty mcdo
it was it was it was really amazing
Watson coach Boulard put that offense
together and an opportunity came at
Alabaman and coach Bryant hired me all
right and what's it like being a
wet-behind-the-ears in a way as you were
with Bear Bryant being the one to tell
you what's what I thought I knew
everything you know I was that young
coach cocky coach on the staff he just
loved to rip my ass I mean every day we
would play the game you know you had to
have the offensive line play had two
quarterbacks play had to run a backs
play and I'd give him my report did you
even watch the film I mean this went on
for like five weeks not going to his
office and how you want a greater coach
you don't find it was just a test to see
if I was gonna keep coming back until I
just said
good and never happen again what do you
think Bruce Arians here in the Rich
Eisen show what do you think he would
think of the conversation is Nick Saban
a greater coach or a more I guess
legendary coach on the campus of Alabama
than Bear Bryant OD as humble as Coach
Bryant was I don't think he'd get in the
conversation he would let that he would
let that up to us you know to everybody
else I know there's there's a
generations of players from the 60s and
70s are gonna argue like hell that
caused riots the best and the young guys
have a right to say Nick's the best and
just one last one on this when you when
you look back at that game last night do
you think do you think Nick Saban is the
best at his profession at that level
Bruce he has the record to prove it I
think there are a lot of great coaches
stuck in schools that can't recruit like
Alabama to say is the greatest coach
he's got the record to prove it mm-hmm
so now let's talk about your decision to
retire when did you make that decision
we had talked about it as a family you
know the weekend after our Thursday
night game this year and again Seattle
oh yeah okay and which was one of those
gut renters that we should have won and
didn't but it really had nothing to do
with it it was time for my wife she was
done and god bless her 47 years in this
business is enough you know and so it
was it was kind of easy but when that
kick missed in Seattle when ours went
through the last game of the season yes
and there's missed mhm I just got a real
calming feeling that made the right
decision and that was that was kind of
the defining moment no kidding so
walking off with the win as you did up
in Seattle that that put it to bed more
because I would think that my might the
coach and you might be like well okay
yeah we were able to do this without
Carson you know without David Johnson at
the end of the season the job our
coaching staff did last seven games with
all those injuries was just amazing and
the players most players tank it when
you're out of the playoffs you got
nothing to play for hmm yeah they'll
play hard to see if we can win when we
can't they tank it right that's just
natural in the league but our guys they
played their tails off and as a credit
to the coaching staff so when when you
say that your wife was done walk me and
the listeners and viewers through what
what was she done with well and what
well the stress the stress of being a
coach's wife of watching my health go up
and down you know with with wins and
losses and and I was I knew I was done
to that that when we made that we had
that conversation and says yeah you're
right there's too much to live for to
die on the sideline and there's nothing
really else to do either win a
championship and I think the Cardinals
can win the championship the talent is
there
Steve camera do whatever he needs to do
to finish off this roster and they'll
hire the right guy so it was easy for me
to step out and just agree with her for
the first time in a long time well not
to get too deep into your HIPAA report
here but was there really a concern that
you you would have a fatal moment on a
sideline if you ever checked my blood
pressure during the game at one doctor
tried to do that years ago and he just
said I don't ever see these numbers
again are you serious you know because I
get a little I get a little hyped up you
know especially with guys in striped
shirts and if it weren't for them it
would be an easy game mMmmm but no it
was last year scarce were i opening from
me you know when I had cancer again and
to beat it didn't like the way the
season ended last year and then have
this one torn apart with injuries but it
just no one has time do you think Carson
stepped away because you did no I think
he knew it was time for him to because
that was the conversation last year is
that you him and Larry all got together
and had sort of a but if I may say so
like a
LeBron Dwyane Wade Chris Bosh sorta
conversation same where the three of us
were attached to the hip no it was it
was all individual it really was it
really was
mine was I wasn't gonna let cancer win a
lot of it was that last year coming back
and this year it was I it's it's time
it's time to go let's go try something
else
okay so do you think Larry is coming
back I think Larry will with the right
situation what is the right situation
the right coach the right offense for
him and a lot of those decisions are
they're gonna be really hard decisions
but I know Michael and Steve will make
the group best decision for the
Cardinals what do you think the decision
for the Cardinals should be oh I would
love to see James Boettcher get the job
I'd like to see it carry over defensive
coordinator yeah just the way the guys
played at the end of season for him and
for all of us but I'm selfish I would I
want to be able to go back you know and
be a part of it
in a small way so yeah I would I was and
I think he's more than qualified not
just for the Cardinals I think he's
ready to be a head coach anywhere
mm-hmm and one last question for you on
this subject what's next for you well
I'm delving into looking at broadcast
and see if there is a spot if someone
thinks I can handle that job I think
would be very exciting to start a new
career okay being on the other side the
dark side the dark side no no no it's
this this is this is the force you're
coming to the jedis yeah okay so now
that I'm with you I feel it well I don't
honor if this spoiler aletter honor if
you're into the Star Wars movies are not
are you Bruce uh okay a little bit all
right but I don't mean to spoil it for
you but at one point Darth Vader does go
back to the light okay okay
just throwing I can't breathe that
heavily well you know so let me do this
I'd like to take a break come back if
you don't mind I'm gonna throw you if
you want to be part of the paparazzi
I'll ask you some questions about what
we're talking about in the media and see
what your to censor on that's good okay
but are you sure you want to do that
yeah
good I like that Bruce Arians what would
know if you don't risk it no biscuit no
biscuit no risk it nobis okay very like
that we'll do that by the way man versus
food again is on Travel Channel every
single Monday night at 9:00 Eastern Time
with our friend Casey Webb this is
definitely not what you're gonna do in
your retirement Bruce that's for sure
which is Edom giant pulled pork sandwich
slathered in hot scorpion red sauce in
ten minutes
no okay a 78 ounce ribeye and two pounds
of mashed potatoes in an hour
Hector Casey Webb is the man doing that
then man vs. food new man new food right
there on Travel Channel back with Bruce
Arians in a moment now I do want to tell
you about true car before we take a
break right now true car over three
million cars have been sold in true cut
by a to true car users by the true car
certified dealer network and the best
part about the true car certified dealer
network is not only that you will get to
know what other people in your Perea
have paid for the same car that you're
looking for but the car that you're
looking for when you go to true car when
you go to their website when you use
their app the car that you are looking
for has a VIN number it exists on the
lot so when you show up to your true car
certified dealer they're not like well
the car that you're looking for we don't
have that house about something similar
how about something else and then you
feel like you're being taken a little
bit which you will never feel like when
you go to a true car certified dealer in
their network over 15,000 true car
certified dealers are nationwide and
true car users save on average over
three thousand dollars off MSRP so when
you're ready to buy a new or used car
visit true cartilage or a more confident
car buying experience some features not
available in all states eight four four
two oh four rich number to dial brett
favre Stila compris Ariane's when we
come back
all right two-time NFL coach of the year
Bruce Arians spending another moment
with us here in studio before Brett
Favre joins us at the top of our number
2 after an incredible national champion
cancer you said to me we went to break
Bruce Lee it's a great game just great
great forefoot can you watch a game just
like a fan or you're always watching
stuff EXO is and stuff like yeah I hate
watching on television cuz I want to run
it back I want the end zone copy I want
to see what really happened on that
cover too at the end of the game
sure well basically the kid looked off
the safety right that's yeah I mean
there was no receiver going down the
middle it looked like mmm and he just
drifted to the hash and said it to the
numbers yeah the old kid should have
been double covered the old 22 now a
couple of quick hitters for you on the
Cardinals real fast it true Stanton
didn't played with no ACL at all is that
true story no drew had he had I don't
think even has one and at me anymore
that's unbelievable and it's just but
he's he had no pain he played fantastic
once he got pain free mm-hmm because he
hurt her than the Seattle game that
Thursday night and finished the game and
once I saw him in practice mobile and it
was really a deep bone bruise mmm that
he really had and but yeah I loved your
stand I just wish him all the best David
Johnson is it true you would compare him
to it I heard you comparing to Franco
Harris that true would you prefer I
think Tom Moore did okay I'm with Tom
coach Franco okay and Tom was on our
staff obviously you know I had rigid cut
criticism for comparing him to Marshall
Fogg because I had Marshall and Indy as
a receiver in a runner the only guy I've
ever seen like David is Marshall but
David's a little bit bigger he is you
know but Marshall was amazingly bright
player to be able to run routes the
David was it why he can play any
position on the field yeah and that's
one of Marshalls greatest attributes he
knows including the quarterback and a
defensive back he knows what everybody's
job yeah that's how he could diagnose it
and know where everything is all right
so now you said you're thinking about
becoming part of the media so let me hit
you on a couple of things that you might
be asked as an analyst in the national
poll
do you think Big Ben is coming back I do
I think a lot of things have to fall in
place for him to come back I
if he wins it all I think he'll try to
do it again okay I think the coaching
staff has a big part of that you know if
they can keep everybody together okay
and how about this one what do you think
the Cardinals should do a quarterback
how about that one well I harassed one
or go get a free agent look at both
what's the best fit for the entire
organization and team hmm if there's a
guy that whoever's running the offense
stuff is a guy that fits and whoever it
is in free agency and he's young enough
I'd still draft one do you like Baker
Mayfield I love his intensity there's a
lot of things that don't like about his
intensity that and I mean I've got an
annoy him a little bit I want to get to
know him a lot better and but I love the
energy he brings to the game so you if
you were sitting in a combine room
sitting there right in the middle of the
first round is the Arizona Cardinals are
you would be quizzing him about what
happened against Kansas is that the sort
of thing you'd be talking those things
you know just the controlling your
emotions a little bit better can you can
you do that without pulling the reins on
him so hard he can't be himself that's
really tricky so who do you think wins
Super Bowl fifty two who do you think
makes it there Bruce Arians well I think
yet three or four the best quarterbacks
to ever play the game
all right and right now it doesn't
matter if you're the sixth seed the home
home-field advantage is almost out to
win two anymore except for a New England
mm-hmm
and I think Pittsburgh can go up there
and win they're going to play really
well but I just think it's gonna be a
great play I helped both championship
games and the Super Bowl as good as what
we just saw last night right but you
have to choose I have to choose right
now losses choose a limb say the Atlanta
Falcons why do you like them
Matty Ryan and just the way their
defense plays their entire there they
have a complete football team special
teams everything
and they just went there so they've got
a little bit of that taste in their
mouth to get this let's get this right
and I don't see them that the Rams are
really good and they played Fairless and
very confident in LA so I think that oh
so you think Atlanta goes through
Philadelphia and then who do you think
it's the Saints of the Vikings this week
I think I'll be the Vikings and that's
where the the old I'm cursed things
comes back to play in your home stadium
to go to the Super Bowl in your home
stadium I think that'd be but there'd be
so much pressure not just that game just
the entire week of practice the two
weeks leading up to having the shot oh
my god
nobody's ever done that daily nobody's
ever had that chance know that and I say
that I mean the shot to actually play
one game at home to stay at home I think
the Falcons win that game and so then
they leave all their belongings for
their for Super Bowl fifty two against
two
who do they see at Pittsburgh I really
believe with Pittsburgh healthy with all
three guys you know not having LaVey on
last year really changed that game and
not having Brown it certainly didn't
help in week 15 right and I have
everybody healthy okay and it'll be a
great game with both teams having
everybody out there it but I like I like
Pittsburgh's overall football team just
a little bit better mm-hmm Steelers vs.
Falcons or Falcons don't tell me the
Falcons lose one more time no George do
you think they take it oh they win what
do you think of Bruce Arians here
everybody its bold its bullying that is
Bolden I was a sixth seed that went all
the way when this thing starts rolling
yeah it's hard to stop it yeah that was
the one that you you want in Tampa with
the Santoni almost out in the I in the
back no the Detroit we were six eight
nine on the road beat Indy when Ben
makes it unbelievable tackle that's
right on Jerome's fumble so he could
just roll off in his hometown and do you
were the one who dialed up the the Hines
Ward to Randall L play the bass yeah I
asked Kenny to call it and Kenny called
it
well oh wait did not you talk was
calling the place okay it's time for it
man it's time for it right yeah that's
Andy called it okay Bruce Arians your
foundation Aryans Family Foundation calm
go to that you've got an event in
Chandler Arizona in the middle of April
correct yes big Gulf German okay and
it's a the Family Foundation motto is a
voice for children supporting and
developing programs which strives to
prevent and ameliorate the abuse and
neglect of children good on you
Congrats on your retirement Congrats to
your wife on your time yeah and and
we'll chat soon I'd love to if not on
the same network then on a show like
this one to promote what you're up to be
my favorite thing to do brother you're a
good man at Bruce Arians on Twitter Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience